hello my name is martin jorginski
and i work at the university of warwick
in this tutorial
i want to give you a gentle introduction
to games
now game theory has been forged
in the famous 1944
monograph by
john von neumann mathematician and
oscar morgenstern an economist and their
goal was to
develop a mathematical theory to reason
about economic behavior
and indeed the title of the book itself
is the theory of games and
economic behavior now
the project has arguably been rather
successful
game theory as a language as set of
methodologies
is by now used as standard in many
social sciences
but also in some natural sciences so one
example is
evolutionary biology in the last 20
30 years game theory has had
quite a vibrant and successful
interaction
with computer science as well that led
to the development of areas such as
algorithmic game theory or algorithmic
mechanism design that have their own
dedicated conferences
and quite a lot of impact including
in industry but also in
areas such as complexity theory where
characterizing the computational
complexity of certain game theoretic
problems and questions has stimulated
creation invention of new complexity
classes and new
computational hardness phenomena
however in this tutorial all or most of
this goodness is
is not really for us instead
because it's a tutorial for the
theoretical foundations of computer
systems
program at simons i'm going to
focus on games that arise from
logic and automata and uh
are in a sense outside of the mainstream
of modern
algorithmic game theory nevertheless
the motivations and applications to
logic automata and
then also to verification and synthesis
are algorithmic and indeed in this
tutorial
my focus and the technical focus is
going to be
on algorithmic questions
a sense this tutorial is going to be
narrower than most of the other ones if
not all of the other ones
in that we are going to focus in
particular
on one model called parity games
now i hope this will still be useful
for uh to some or maybe even
many of you given that parity games
in fact the computational complexity
of parity games ought to be even more
specific
the question whether there is a
polynomial time algorithm
to solve parity games is an open
question
has been open for quite a while and it's
very accessible
i believe strongly believe that there
isn't
much that anyone needs to learn in order
to
start engaging with the problem
meaningfully so hopefully
in this program we'll find opportunities
for doing so but before
i tell you about games on graphs
and party games in particular
let's go let's let's ask ourselves um
why games on graphs what are the reasons
why
games on graphs are interesting and i'm
going to
showcase a few classic problems
in automata theory logic
and their applications to verification
and synthesis where games on graphs
and in particular parity games arise
we're going to start with
an application to tree automata
complementation
it's a classic result of rabin
that has been already mentioned in
tutorials by
mikowi and orna
and my goal here
will be to actually give you a fairly
rigorous
detailed proof of determinacy
of parity games which is one of the key
technical tools that are used
in the proof of the difficult proof
of rabin's result that tree automata
can be effectively complemented but
before we go there
let me give you a very primitive in a
way
very simple very general model
of games that we are going to consider
in this tutorial
so games on graphs that we are going to
consider are played
by two players for now let's call them
one
and two player one and player two
although
very soon we are going to
give them various names depending on
context
these two players play on a graph and
what they do is that they interact
in a very sim very simple way namely
they
pick edges and who picks
the next edge to follow
depends on who is the owner of the
current vertex
so the vertices in this graph often will
be referred to as positions
the edges in our graph will often be
referred to as
moves and we have a partition of the set
of vertices
into those that are owned by player 1
and those
that are owned by player 2.
so that's one part of the specification
of the game
which describes what the arena so to say
on which the game is played
and what the rules
of movement are in the game
now there is the other component which
in this very
general formulation is simply
a set of infinite paths
in the graph and you should think of
this
set as a referee once players
complete their infinite interaction in
which
they jointly
pick an infinite path
that set the referee so to say
will determine who the winner is
indeed we will say that player 1 wins
an infinite path in our graph g
if and only if that infinite path
is a member of set w1
otherwise it will be player 2
who is the winner of such a path now how
do players form such a path let's be
very specific
they start in some vertex some
dedicated vertex that's called v0 and
then
whenever the current vertex knows the
current vertex at the beginning and then
whenever
current vertex v i
belongs to
the set of vertices owned by
player one or two
so the owner of the vertex
moves to another vertex which happens to
be connected by a directed edge
from the current vertex and that the
next vertex becomes the current vertex
so that's how players interact in order
to
form an infinite path so this model is
very basic very primitive in a way and i
told you that
we will often focus in this tutorial on
party games so let me tell you what a
party game is
so here is an example of a parody game
which is played on
this finite graph with four vertices
and the
what we often refer to as the winning
condition that set of infinite paths
that are winning for play for one of the
two players
uh here is going to be um represented
in a special way it's going to be
represented by
uh this function which labels every
vertex
by a positive integer and some range
from
1 to d so
every vertex is labeled by an orange
number
and we call the number of each of those
vertices
its priority so this is a bit of jargon
that is
used in parity games now why parity
games
uh in a party game we have two players
we will call them even and odd
and the pictures that i draw i typically
represent
vertices owned by even by squares now
it's easy to remember because
squares have four sides and four is even
and i will tend to represent
or draw vertices or positions
owned by player odd
either by triangles or maybe pentagons
if triangles are too hard
to draw but both pentagons and triangles
have three sides and hence it's easy to
note that they belong to player odd
so this is a party game now i will often
refer to because we are interested in
algorithms
i will often refer to the size of a
parity game if it is a finite
parity game in the sense that it's on a
finite graph
i will often denote it by n
and try to keep it blue on the slides as
much as possible
so we know how party games are played
because they are games on graphs and
games on graphs and this tutorial always
get played in the same
way we start at a certain vertex and
then the
owner of that vertex in this case even
because we have here we have a square
picks one of the outgoing edges there
too either the self loop
or this one and in this illustration
we always choose the fat edges
or the players choose the fat edges and
hence the resulting play
here this edge is chosen by even
then this edge is chosen by odd and then
this edge is chosen by odd this edge
that edge
and forever the two players interact
to form a path which consists of the
prefix
and infinite repetition
of this three cycle
now how is this labeling by priorities
determining the winner
how does the arbiter work here
well here's the definition we'll say
that
even wins a sequence of vertices
so in other words the sequence of
vertices belongs to the winning
set of winning plays for even
if and only if that's that's a really
if you see it for the first time it may
seem really
um ad hoc here's the condition
additions the condition says that the
highest priority that occurs
infinitely often or in other words the
limb soup
of the priorities of all vertices that
occur
in that infinite play is an even number
now it does exist because
there are only finitely many integers
even if
the graph itself was
infinite in the parity games that we
consider here
we only allow a finite number
of priorities so that number
certainly exists and if it is even that
even wins if it is odd
then audwins now i will not blame you if
you find this definition
crazy and hot hog but i hope
to convince you that
it is not as frivolous
as it seems and in fact it
really plays a very central role in
the applications of automata in logic
that you have for example seen in
mikowi's tutorial and indeed
as discussed by orna in her tutorial
on automata
our first motivating example
of the uses of games on graphs
and parity games in particular is
the famous result of rapine
that satisfiability for the monadic
second or the logic
on infinite trees is
so this is one of those um first and
very influential
examples of the use of the automata
method
that mikowice tutorial is about
for showing decidability of
logics the technical core
of rabin's solution of this problem
is a proof that automata on
infinite trees non-deterministic
automata
on infinite trees can be effectively
complemented
in or in other words that there is an
algorithm
that given an automaton on trees
produces another automaton that
recognizes
all the trees that are not accepted
by the original automaton now
as mccoy has pointed out this is a
complex and subtle proof
but by now it has been digested by many
generations of
of researchers because the techniques
in rabin's proof were so fruitful
to study other problems
and by now we have proofs that are
fairly
well streamlined uh conceptually
clean and elegant teachable
and many of those have
two main technical
ingredients or components one of them
and both of those are non-trivial
results
one of them is determinization of
automata
on infinite words that's something that
you will have learned from ornas horna's
tutorial and this is indeed a highly
non-trivial
topic with
several solutions and ongoing
research on making
this algorithmically feasible
the second component is positional
determinancy
of games um and in the modern treatments
of the proof of rabin's theorem
the games the specific games for which
we
want determinacy and in fact positional
determinancy
which i will explain soon are indeed
parity games
but first of all what is the game
so imagine that we have a tree automaton
three automaton a
now a trio automata has a set of states
an
input alphabet it has an acceptance
criterion on acceptance condition
which like games that we have introduced
can be thought of as a subset of
sequences infinite sequences in this
case it supports subsets of
subset of infinite sequences
of states of the automaton and of course
in order
for the automaton to be finite we want
some finitary representations and one of
them is
indeed assigning priorities to states of
the automaton
and um using the parity condition
whenever we want to
define acceptance of a structure
like in this case the binary tree
by an automaton typically we define
a concept of a run but this is a
tutorial about games
so let me give you an alternative and
equivalent definition
in terms of what sometimes is called
the acceptance game so here is an
acceptance game
for a tree automaton a a
non-deterministic tree
automaton a by the way
there is an initial state missing here
so there should be either
an initial state or a set of initial
states
um but we have an acceptance game
on an automaton and a specific tree
where the tree is understood as a
labeling
with letters from some alphabet sigma of
that alphabet sigma
of all the nodes in the tree which uh in
the case of the
complete binary tree uh are simply
sequences
finite finite sequences of zeros and
ones
so um what is the game what is the
acceptance game
which will uh determine whether a tree
is accepted by the automatic 3t is
accepted by an automat by the automaton
a
or not in this game there are two
players
we call one automaton and the other
the pathfinder and the intuition here is
that the automaton aims to show
that the tree is in the language of the
automaton
or in other words the task of the
automaton will be to
build to construct or to prove that they
can
construct successfully construct an
accepting run
of the automaton on the other hand the
task of the pathfinder is to
try to disprove that try to
show that the 3t in fact is not in the
language
accepted by the automaton a so the task
of the pathfinder here would be to
prove to provide evidence that there
is no accepting run of the automaton
a on 3t so we are going to capture
this condition instead game
theoretically
so the we have two players the automaton
and the pathfinder
but what are the positions and moves and
then what is the
winning condition well the positions
are going to be of two types there will
be either pairs
a node in the tree so a node is always a
finite sequence of zeros and once and a
state
of the automaton and the other type of
nodes
will consist of a other type of
positions will consist of
a node again and a pair of states
now it will be the automaton who owns
and hence moves picks an outgoing edge
from positions of the form node
state and it'll be the pathfinder who
will
make moves in positions of the form node
and a pair of states now the intuition
here is that the automaton
is in fact going to pick transitions
so if the automaton
is at the node n of the tree
so here we have an illustration of a
tree
and the current state in the run that
the automaton is trying to construct
is q then the automaton can pick
out of all the possible transitions
from state q and upon reading letter
t of n which is exactly the label of
node n
uh each of those transitions gives a
pairs of pair of states
and the intuition here is that these
pairs of states denote the states that
according to this transition
non-deterministic transition are going
to be sent
to the left and the right children of
node n
now it's a game rather than
doing both as we would in the concept of
run
we let the opponent the pathfinder to
pick which direction they want to move
in
in other words what the automaton needs
to do is to
get it to demonstrate that they can
continue
successful runs from both q 0 and the
left child of n
and q 1 and the right child of n
now the pathfinder is going to
have a choice of either going to the
left
by proceeding to node
and concatenated concatenated with zero
or to the node
and concatenated with one and then from
there
try to disprove the claim by the
automaton that they can construct
a run starting from respectively
uh state q0 and q1
but what does it mean for a player
to strive or to aim to achieve something
well we are going to formalize it using
the concept of a winning strategy so
what is a winning strategy
in a game on a graph like the games we
are considering here
it will be a function sigma which
for any finite sequence of vertices
the last of which belongs to that player
i
gives us another vertex now of course it
needs to be a valid move
so what must be the case in order for
such a function to
be a strategy is that
if strategy sigma
yields vertex w or position w
on this prefix or history of the play so
far
which ends with with vertex or position
v k
then v k w is an edge
in the graph so in other words the
strategy provides
valid moves now if you think about it
and take two strategies say sigma one
and sigma two
one for player one and the other player
two
and if you start in some initial vertex
v
or v um
and each of the players follows
their strategy either sigma 1 or sigma 2
in this sense and
should be quite clear that what's going
to happen is that
that will uniquely determine uh
the infinite path starting at that
vertex v and that follows those two
strategies sigma one and sigma two
okay so so so with this concept of a
path determined by
complete description of what each of the
two players are doing according to their
uh strategy sigma 1 and sigma 2 we can
now define
what it means for a strategy for one of
the players say strategy sigma 1
for player 1 to be a winning strategy
for her
from some initial vertex v so it will be
the case
if it is if for every strategy sigma 2
of player 2 so in other words no matter
how player 2 behaves it is always going
to be the case
that the unique path that is obtained by
starting at v and then following sigma 1
and sigma 2
is a win for player 1. so now with the
rigorous definition of
a winning strategy in a game
we are ready to define
what it when a tree is accepted
by an automaton name firstly
let's clarify that an infinite path
in this acceptance game
in which we alternate between positions
of the form
node state and node pair of states
is x is winning for the automaton
if it is the case that the sequence of
states that occur
in these positions of the form node
state and ignoring the position's node
pair of states
so if the sequence in the second
coordinates of
the automaton states
is a sequence in this acceptance
condition of the automaton
so now we can say that the automaton a
accepts 3t if and
only if player automaton
has a winning strategy
starting from the
node of the tree which is its root
and from
one of the initial states
right so let's maybe try to understand
better
the concept of a winning strategy and in
particular
uh the concept of winning strategy for
even
in a parity game so here's an example of
a parity game
with
10 vertices 10 positions
and six distinct priorities from
one to six and
perhaps it may take a bit of time for
you to
figure out whether even has a winning
strategy
in this game or not and if so
from which vertices is the answer yes
and from which vertices
is the answer no um
i'd like to now help you and
convince you that in fact even
in this party game with 10 vertices
10 positions has a winning strategy from
every starting vertex
and indeed the strategy of player even
in this game is
of a very simple form it's a very
uh important useful concept um
it's a positional strategy what does
mean for a strategy to be positional
well it means that in this strategy
the move that is picked by the player
which is an outgoing edge from the
current vertex
is completely independent of how we have
arrived to that vertex what the history
of the play
so far is where it has started
uh which vertices this visited in what
order
and how many times all of this is
irrelevant
when you arrive at the vertex the
positional strategy will always
tell you to follow the same edge
so here's an example of a position
strategy which by the way can be
formalized as a function from positions
owned by even
to set of vertices in this parity game
we have
four different vertices that belong to
even they are the squares all the others
are triangles and hence they belong to
uh to odd and the edges
that are dictated by a positional
strategy the green positional strategy
here
are simply the green edges so now i'd
like to
convince you that this
positional strategy is winning for even
in this parody game
and the way to do it is to do the
following very simple
mental exercise simply ignore all the
edges that player even will never use
they are the thin edges this one this
one
and this one and this one
so let's let's just throw them out and
indeed
let's also forget which vertices are
vertices of player even and which
vertices are
where player odd moves let's just ignore
that because
from now on every edge is possible
right we have committed to a single
outgoing edge from every
from every square
but the opponent can do whatever they
then please
and whenever they want to do that
so all edges are in place so let's keep
all the edges outgoing from
uh positions owned by odd but let's only
include the green edges
that were picked uh in that positional
strategy for
for player even so what we now have
is what i call the strategy graph
right so the strategy graph is the one
without the thin edges it's only the
outgoing green edges and of course all
the outgoing edges for the opponent
and i hope that if you stare at this
graph
much shorter than before you will
convince yourself that every
cycle in this finite graph is even
and from that it's an easy exercise to
conclude
that every path in this finite
graph with priorities on vertices has
the property
that the highest priority that occurs
infinitely many times
is even and indeed in this example
somehow the principle of movement
is that you either go
left or you go
up and whenever you go up
you go to a vertex with a very high
even priority higher than what you've
seen
recently okay so so that's a very useful
picture to keep in mind it will underpin
one of the key concepts of an attractor
decomposition
that we are going to study in this
tutorial
now let's talk about determinacy
we say that a game is determined from
a vertex v if it is the case
that at least one of the two players has
a winning strategy right so here we have
a statement that
there is a strategy for player 1
such that for every strategy of player 2
the unique play that
results from following those two
strategies starting with vertex v
is a win for player 1 and here's an
equivalent
an analogous statement about existence
of a winning strategy for player 2 from
that same
starting vertex v and
if this dichotomy holds
then we would say the game is determined
from vertex v and then we would say that
the game is determined
if it is determined from every starting
vertex now it is very tempting to think
that clearly if one player cannot win
the other must
be able to well indeed this the
situation is not
that wrong because uh this dichotomy
holds
um for all finite games and holds quite
um naturally there is a standard
a very natural procedure called
sometimes called backwards induction
which allows you to
to show that every finite game in which
every play
results in a win or or loss
or win for one of the players is
determined
in the sense of this dichotomy holding
that's why
we know that if you exclude
um by tweaking the rules if you exclude
draws in say
chess either black or white
have a winning strategy we just don't
know which one that is
because the game is just too large but
it's finite
so in this sense it's really trivial
it's determined because all finite games
of perfect information let's not go into
technical details here
is determined on the other hand with
infinite games
things get tricky and indeed there are
non-determined games for example
using the axiom of choice one can
construct one
there are some funky constructions of
non-determined games
uh let's not go there here but
it's useful to keep that in mind
as a cautionary cautionary
matter
so this issue of when games are
determined has been studied
and has been studied by set theorists in
fact
gale and stewart have been first
to pose the question
of whether games
are determined depending on their
topological complexity or
rather on the topological complexity
of their the winning sets
so here is a natural topology on the set
of
infinite sequences of positions
or on infinite paths
in the game graph so the basic open sets
are defined to be the cylinders which
are simply the sets
of all infinite paths which have the
same
prefix pi so we have a cylinder for
every
finite prefix pi
and then the open sets are simply unions
of all
of basic open sets
and a natural hierarchy
of sets of increasing complexity
is the so-called borel sets
which sort of at the bottom of the
hierarchy have open sets
and we say that the set is burrell
if it is um
if it can be obtained from open sets by
two kinds of operations either
complementation
or countable unions now note that if you
have
countable unions and complementation
then you also have countable
intersections this is this is a
a subtle um right so the construction of
braille sets is quite subtle and
it's in particular it's not true that
there are only uh
finite levels of uh of uh
boreal sets because we have countable
unions so we can do some kind of
diagonalization and
go beyond all the finite levels uh or
levels that result from just finite
number of applications of a
complementation or accountable union uh
so it's quite it's a very rich rich
family of sets
um and it was galen stewart who have
uh shown uh early in 1950s
that uh and that proof is is not
difficult
uh that every open game is determined
right so every
uh game in which the winning condition
the winning criterion
uh is an open set is determined it's a
bit
harder than doing it for clopen sets
because games with cloak and winning
sets are essentially equivalent to
finite games
but they pose the question whether you
can climb the borough hierarchy
and it was martin in a rather
complex and and uh impressive result
who has shown that um every game with a
braille
uh winning condition is determined so so
that's that's a very powerful
powerful result sometimes can be useful
as a big hammer if you want to establish
whether
some tricky game that you are
considering is determined or not
you could use uh you could use martin's
martin's theorem so so so i have an
exercise for you
prove that the set of
sequences or paths
that are winning with respect to the
party condition
namely that the highest priority that
occurs
infinitely many times is even
is indeed a borel set so if
you are not familiar with burl hierarchy
and borrel sets
it's it's a useful exercise but
wait a minute why did we start talking
about
party games at all well here is one
answer
in 1966 mcnaughton has proved
this very influential result that every
non-deterministic behe word automaton
can be determinized so there is another
equivalent deterministic word automaton
however
deterministic beefy automata are less
expressive than non-deterministic bihu
automata
so this result cannot possibly hold
for deterministic bihi
automata so what are the alternatives
and in fact
maknoton used automata with an
acceptance condition called
amala condition then
later safra has significantly improved
the complexity
of mcnaughton's construction
which was very influential and
led to lots of work
which i will mention later
but
and and
safra used another acceptance condition
called
rabin condition but nowadays there are
constructions
including those by petermann
later by cheva and others
that yield directly
a parity automata and parity automata
have various benefits
one of which is that
party games are positionally determined
and that turns out to be particularly uh
convenient technically in various
contexts
so this result of emerson and jatla from
early 1990s that every party game
is positionally determined that is
from every starting vertex one of the
two players
has a positional winning strategy
turns out to make working with parity
automata particularly convenient
so finally let's see
uh just a sketch of
the construction in this hard part
of rabin's result which is the
complementation
of tree automata
so we defined acceptance
of a tree by an automaton using a game
in which we had two players called
automaton
and pathfinder and we defined
3t being accepted by
an automaton or in other words belonging
to the language accepted by the
automaton
if it was the automaton player who had a
winning strategy
now if we want to construct an automaton
that accepts exactly all those trees
that are
not accepted by a
then we can use determinacy to conclude
that we need to
we want to accept exactly all those
trees
in which for which the acceptance game
the game based on the automaton and the
tree
is such that pathfinder has a positional
winning
strategy in that acceptance game right
because by determinacy we know that if
automaton doesn't have a winning
strategy then pathfinder pathfinder does
and one way to provide a modern proof
of uh this difficult result by rabin
is to construct an automaton let's call
it
a bar in such a way
that what it's going to do is that it's
going to guess
that's where we use non-determinism
then verify in parallel simultaneously
verify um
a whole positional winning strategy
for pathfinder in the acceptance game
right so this automaton
a bar will be able to accept a tree
if and only if it is capable
of guessing and verifying confirming
that a strategy that it has guessed a
strategy for pathfinder
is indeed winning for pathfinder and
hence it is impossible
for the automaton to accept that tree
because
otherwise it would be the opponent who
has a winning strategy
and and that's impossible so now
this process of guessing and verifying
a whole winning strategy for pathfinder
is quite subtle and
both determinization
of word automata and
determinacy of games and in fact
crucially
what is sometimes referred to as
forgetful or finite memory
determinancy but if we are lucky enough
to have
the party acceptance condition
in fact you don't need memory at all
positional
strategies are memoryless
those two components allow
the subtle process to succeed
they allow for this verification
of for guessing and the verification of
the guest
strategy for pathfinder to be done using
a finite automaton entries
so we will not go into
all all the gory details of that but
i think it's very useful to be aware
of the importance of positional
determinacy
and of determinization of automaton
words when we want to complement
automata
on infant trees and
thanks to the result of
um mcnaughton safra
and their followers
all we need to consider is
acceptance games with parity conditions